regardez c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
comme d'habitude c'est coupé comme un
porte quoi voilà ils ont envie il y
avait un montage à faire il fallait
prendre l'extrait de Jean-Marc Morandini
tout simplement ils ont pas su le faire
qui est choqué moi pour moi je dis bravo
une fois de plus et j'ai reconnu la
chanson
[Rires]
non non mais franchement moi là je dis
bravo la question c'est quoi la question
d'ailleurs
choque les téléspectateurs qui est
choqué qui êtes-vous choqué alors oui
oui qui dit non déjà ceux qui sont
d'accord avec moi après je prendrai je
dis oui bien sûr parce que c'est ce qui
va être le plus intéressant c'est les
oui ah oui non mais souvent je me
demande pourquoi la France a un
incroyable talent marche et pas de
divertissement sur d'autres chaînes par
exemple ma singer parce que dans cette
émission on voit des choses qu'on ne
voit nulle part les vannes du jury c'est
pareil on aime on n'aime pas mais ils
osent avoir un ton un peu corrosif et la
preuve c'est qu'on en parle tout le
monde a parlé dessus aujourd'hui
je suis d'accord avec toi voilà ils ont
quelque chose voilà thème ou tu aimes
pas moi ils ne font pas ouvrir
exactement
c'est tellement dur aujourd'hui
il est tellement jeune c'est tellement
dur d'exister pour un programme télé
d'aujourd'hui que eux au moins ils
réussissent à faire parler d'eux avec
des des sketchs un peu spectaculaires et
ça sort de toutes ces émissions
aseptisées qu'on voit partout à la
chaîne et vous le savez je vous dis tout
franchement j'ai aucun intérêt à le dire
les deux émissions et je dis et je pense
que nous il se passe un truc franchement
tous les sorts voilà qui fait un truc et
il y a deux autres pour moi il se passe
des trucs L'Amour est dans le pré la
France a un Incroyable les deux
émissions c'est vrai voilà ou vraiment
tu te dis tu vas voir des trucs que tu
vois pas ailleurs et c'est pour ça que
ça cartonne incroyable talent et l'Amour
est dans le pré c'est deux formats qui
cartonnent parce que M6 va plus loin que
les autres les autres et franchement ils
ont peur de tout ils font rien c'est
c'est aseptisé on se fait chier là qui
pensait voir un numéro comme ça
les mineurs sortaient de la salle j'ai
franchement moi j'étais j'ai dit bravo
franchement bravo alors il y a toujours
les relous comme Gilles Verdez qui vont
dire c'est inadmissible mais des mecs
voilà qui n'ont jamais fait de télé
populaire Gilles Verdez à part ici mais
c'est vrai que voilà tu fais seul
c'était pas très populaire là ça c'est
de la télé populaire c'est de la télé
pour moi qui a des qui a des coronesses
c'est inadmissible
je vais donner 500000 € que je vais
donner la castelier
elle joue du pipeau avec son vagin en
prime time Cyril non mais c'est honteux
alors ça je le vois tous les jours
non mais j'étais au solfège encore la
semaine dernière voilà je suis désolé
non alors on te on fait sortir les
jeunes de moins de 18 ans c'est une
humiliation pour eux de la salle après
on met juste un carton moins de 10 ans
pour moi ça ne suffit pas franchement
c'est choquant c'est pas populaire c'est
dégradant j'ai trouvé que c'était moi
pour le cadeau pour qui veut voir ça
pour le public de voir ça
pour regarder Cyril
on voit une très belle chatte l'emoji
désolé
et cette dame est gynéco ouais oui
absolument c'est l'exhibition du sexe
pour on prétend un motif artistique
alors que ce n'est que de la vulgarité
c'est-à-dire dans un instant vous allez
voir on aura les Adidas parce que je
disais que c'est d'autres émissions qui
cartonne vous allez voir alors là on a
fait les les ADP d'or d'Arca
coulissements forts les amours et dans
le pré d'or ça ça va être très fort
aussi mais il se passe quelque chose
dans ADP et dans La France a un
incroyable talent je suis désolé
Delphine vous êtes choqué oui parce
qu'effectivement comme vous l'avez dit
et généralement
[Applaudissements]
généralement il ne se passe rien sur les
autres chaînes et donc du coup ils ont
voulu faire un petit buzz et ils ont
autorisé ça la semaine dernière il y a
Ruby donc l'influenceuse qui vend
l'autre son bain elle a enlevé son
t-shirt elle était en soutif limite
c'est un peu choqué les gens et on s'est
dit qu'est-ce qui va se passer le
lendemain dans la presse si vous vous
faites venir une nana avec ça avec son
vagin
qu'est-ce qui va se passer là on dit
chapeau l'artiste parce qu'il se passe
jamais rien sur les autres chaînes et
donc il y a c'est quelque chose de
d'artistique demain inviter quelqu'un
qui fait du pipeau comme ça je suis pas
sûr que ça sera on m'a demandé de faire
la Une de vulve magazine
non non mais alors moi
parce que les gens sont énervés parce
qu'on est voilà on les voilà c'est sûr
que tu vas avoir un article dans le truc
qui servent à rien liberation ou des
mecs qui ont deux abonnés sur Twitter ou
des chats rouges comme ça mais on s'en
fout de ça ou je suis comme ça mais je
les appelle pour moi c'est des chat
voilà je te dis mais à La France a un
incroyable talent pourquoi il se
permettrait pas de le faire moi je
trouve que voilà c'est la télé qu'on
veut voilà tel ou tu aimes pas bah si tu
aimes pas tu zappes bah hier il y a 3
millions de personnes qui les ont vu et
sur les moins de 50 ans ils étaient
leader je suis désolé donc voilà donc
les gens ils ont envie de se marrer
aussi ils ont envie de boire autre chose
à la télé et la France a un incroyable
talent ou L'Amour est dans le pré et ben
il propose des choses qu'on voit pas
ailleurs quand tu vois la galoche sur
l'amour et dans le pré donc quel autre
émission tu vois des galoches frère non
mais sans déconner sur TF1 frère tu vois
pas des galoches c'est rassera ils sont
tous habillés euh chez brucefild avec
des chaussures Minelli ils sont ils sont
avec leurs micromain on a l'impression
d'avoir d'être dans la télé des années
90 M6 ils vivent en 2022 je suis désolé
TF1 et alors France Télévisions on en
parle même pas France Télévisions frère
c'est c'est la télé des ancêtres non
mais c'est vrai France 5 frérot on vous
sait même pas si bouge encore encore les
gars tu vois la télé franchement ils
sont tous comme as on dirait que tu es
au musée grémin sans déconner mes frères
arrêtez il y a Patrick Cohen sur France
5 frère le gars on sait même pas si
bouge encore
non mais arrêtez ça voilà ça c'est de la
télé oui alors toi tu es choqué toi
alors choqué et
moi j'en ai juste à la place je vais à
la place des parents qui ont leurs
enfants qui sont dans la télévision
ouais d'accord on passe bien sûr
la tête à l'envers avec une flûte dans
le dans la faune
de France Inter elle a dit qu'elle
allait faire la même chose
avec un trombone
je peux comprendre que ça interroge
après chérie bon dire que c'est une
prise de risque de de montrer ça bon
voilà c'est pas non plus une prise de
risque énorme et c'est vrai que si après
les pas qu'est-ce que tu veux dire ça
fait deux heures on sait pas ce que tu
veux dire regardez qu'est-ce que tu vas
dire ça fait deux heures qui suivent
si votre fille vous dit tiens je voulais
faire de la flûte que vous allez
qu'est-ce que j'en ai à peu près
c'est pas nul c'est pas question
racontes n'importe quoi c'est la fille
veut dire qu'il veut faire de la flûte
elle a 45 ans elle est gynécologue bah
c'est normal quand tu vois
là je peux dire quand tu es gynéco tu as
envie de faire de la flûte avec
les ORL ils le font éclairer d'ailleurs
c'est juste super non mais si on n'aime
pas encore une fois le jury
on regarde d'accord donc on est pénalisé
alors
pourquoi toi ça te choque c'est pour
avoir un problème
sur France Inter
chez les médiocres
non parce que non non non non quand on
aime pas on zappe tu aimes pas ça je
suis d'accord
merci Raymond moi je suis d'accord si tu
aimes pas tu zappes sauf que quand vous
prenez L'Amour est dans le pré L'Amour
est dans le pré vous allez jamais voir
ça dedans quand vous n'a rien à voir
naturellement moi ça me choque pas j'ai
46 ans je suis pas choqué mais je peux
me dire qu'un programme télé regardez
par des enfants merci tu es obligé de
changer de chaîne et revenir après et si
c'était un incroyable talent un talent
tu dis pas à tes enfants sors il y a un
talent qui arrive
si c'était un vrai talent tu regardes en
famille et un vrai talent c'est un vrai
talent dans le Grand Cabaret
là
je te dis mais c'est pas un talent ça
prend une fois
ça prouve que c'est si tu comprends
c'est du divertissement et grand cabaret
ça n'a rien à voir là c'est une
respiration humoriste dans le programme
[Rires]
tu tu changes si tu t'es gêné parce que
et tu reviens ce que j'aimerais voir
c'est cette meuf là qui ferait l'amour
en incroyable talent dans le pré
et quand vous l'avez vu vous êtes tous
dit waouh mais quel talent
[Musique]
c'est un divertissement c'est un
spectacle ou tu te dis j'ai envie de
voir des trucs nuls aussi et ça moi je
dis franchement je le redis et vraiment
c'est ça n'engage que moi bravo M6 bravo
à la production parce que là ils ont
montré qu'ils avaient et ben ils sont
dit c'est quoi on y va parce qu'ils ont
dû se poser la question est-ce qu'on le
met pas et ils l'ont mis bravo à eux je
te suis désolé ce qui est incroyable on
en a marre d'une télé aseptisée on en a
marre d'une télé France 5 l'évolution
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
nationale où on fait le plus tout et
n'importe quoi c'est incroyable
ici vous oseriez pas demain
à côté on fera Castaldi avec l'amour est
dans le pays
elle peut très bien
vous direz non là c'est trop touchant
vous allez pas prendre un risque de
faire venir une nana en porte-jarretelle
qui fait de la flûte avec ça non parce
que non
mais avec la chatte
la petite chatte
mais non Cyril oserait
tout faire et pour autant il y a des
choses qui sont de mauvais goût et ça ça
en est la preuve
[Applaudissements]
des choses que même le CSA même de
censurerait pas moi je me rappelle une
époque à TF1 on ne pouvait même pas dire
merde à l'antenne et c'est parce que les
programmes sont lancés
alors franchement
la veste de Daniel c'est pas ça
lui depuis tout à l'heure il m'appelle
et quand je lui donne la parole il a
rien à dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est-ce que tu veux là
franchement vous connaissez quand même
que si vous faisiez la séquence ici
alors attention vous parce que je
faisais des guerres il va voir mais
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire ça et tu vas
faire quoi bah je peux pas je bois mes
frères les dia le temps que tu arrives
déjà Titi va se passer quoi l'émission
sera finie je serai chez
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme les méchants dans les films
d'horreur tu as marqué dans les méchants
il est quand même le gars
maintenant c'est Usain Bolt et le gars
je le garde maintenant il court dans la
forêt mon frère t'as jamais vu un gars
toi aussi et tu as un gars qui déboîte
comme un Célia salut et il le rattrape à
chaque fois sans déconner fais gaffe non
mais attaque personne tu as déjà perdu
un genou à partir